la défense anti-aérienne russe mise à
rude épreuve depuis plusieurs semaines
qui est multiplie les attaques de drones
jusqu'à l'intérieur de Moscou dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche 3 drones sont
repérés dans le ciel de la capitale
russe l'un d'entre eux frappe un
immeuble du quartier d'affaires
une stratégie assumée et une nouvelle
étape du conflit que veut enclencher qui
est graduellement la guerre va retourner
sur le territoire de la Russie frapper
ses centres symboliques et ses bases
militaires c'est un processus inévitable
et surtout juste des attaques qui n'ont
pas fait de mort mais cible des points
stratégiques tant sur le plan militaire
que psychologique les Ukrainiens
attaquent tous les jours et en
particulier la nuit cette digue brique
par brique et quand il apercevront ils
ont de fortes chances de submerger les
forces russes qui derrière ont des
nombres problèmes logistiques des
problèmes de commandement et surtout le
moral dans les chaussettes si Vladimir
Poutine n'a pas commenté la dernière
attaque son entourage prévient un
élargissement du conflit constituerait
une escalade dangereuse